[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
horcruxes ron hermione and the dursleys
more specifically
we're going to be discussing how harry
affected those around him
given that he was indeed one of
voldemort's horcruxes
when voldemort killed lily evans and
james potter his next target was baby
harry
the prophecy foretold by sybil trelawny
threatened voldemort's reign of power
specifically the boy born at the end of
july harry
thanks to lily evans loving sacrifice
harry was never killed
and the killing curse that voldemort
fired came right back
at him this effectively split
voldemort's soul
turning harry into a horcrux the next
thing you know
voldemort was defeated and the wizarding
world was sighing in relief
however not everyone was celebrating for
you see
harry's parents were now dead which
meant that he was without a family
in order to keep harry safe he was left
at the doorstep of the dursey family
where harry's aunt petunia and uncle
vernon lived
at first this might sound like the worst
place for harry to be
but you see as long as harry lived under
their roof as long as he could call
their home his
he was safe harry grew up in an
environment that certainly could have
been better
a place where his dreams were stomped on
and his presence was not often
acknowledged
the dursleys were terrible people but
one thing about harry's upbringing that
some fans have theorized
is their poor behavior was a result of
harry's horcrux
one of the properties of a horcrux is
that it can make people do
strange things and can change their
behavior for the worse
horcruxes are dark magical artifacts
that shouldn't be tampered with but here
harry was
a horcrux himself but here's the big
question
if harry being a horcrux was the reason
that the jerseys were so terrible
then why didn't harry affect ron or
hermione's mood why would they
able to remain good people in the
presence of harry
in essence the reason for this is that
harry isn't a proper
full-blown horcrux when voldemort
traveled to godric's hollow and tried to
kill harry
the curse rebounded which split
voldemort's soul however
because voldemort's body was gone the
victim of his own curse
he could no longer encase the soul
fragment to complete the hawker's
creation
part of horcrux creation involves an
encasing spell
which actually puts the soul outside of
the body into a physical object
because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment
it latched itself to harry for this
reason harry contained voldemort's soul
fragment
but was never possessed by it therefore
he did not possess
a lot of the main characteristics of a
horcrux if harry being a horcrux was the
cause of the dursley's anger
then it would make no sense that no one
else would be affected for this reason
i'm of the belief that harry simply
wasn't horcrux enough
to affect those around him one
workaround for this could be that only
muggles are sensitive to the horcrux
inside of him
but i think that's a bit of a stretch
and that's it for this video
did you know that harry isn't a proper
horcrux did you ever wonder about this
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry
you